It's Christmas time! It's cold here at McKinley.
It's Christmas! We are singing some Christmas carols which I'm really excited about 'cause I love Christmas.
Everybody's in sweaters and scarves, and it's fun.
This is the most Christmassy it's been in a very long time.
"God Rest Ye Merry Gentlemen" and "Angels We Have Heard on High"...
...are my favorite songs from the Christmas soundtrack.
Naya kills "God Rest Ye Merry Gentlemen".
She comes in and that's like "Whoa!"
Like, I really wanna listen to her right now. Can it be playing in the background?
I was way into the magic of Christmas as a kid. I used to look at the tree...
...and try to get in the mood. You just love them.
Merry Christmas and Happy Holidays.
I would like to wish you all a Happy Holiday.
Just wanna wish everybody a very Merry Christmas and a Happy New Year.
Happy holidays.